if you're watching us on Facebook we
thank you if you're watching us on
YouTube liar no one's watching us on
YouTube because they actually blocked us
in the middle of the broadcast for using
the same stream that the Young Turks are
also using on YouTube without being
blocked what do you do about that well
follow us over at Facebook or visit the
daily wire.com become a subscriber not
only do you get the delightful leftist
here's how to roll tumblr for $9.99 but
you can actually hear what we're saying
now that I think about it makes almost
no sense that I'm pitching this that
you're not already on one of those
platforms you aren't listening this is
why you guys are actually the
broadcaster's and I'm the the god king
is not all-knowing wouldn't predict for
instance that YouTube would take us down
for using a publicly owned stream right
that the Young Turks is also using
without any concept right there's no
bias right people on Facebook to go over
to YouTube and hit the bell yeah people
should go over to that YouTube and hit
the bell so if they can be notified when
we don't have a feed we're gonna take a
few questions from the audience because
we we got a good hour of in and
then the president got one hour plus
four and a half hours we want to hear
from you head on over to Facebook ask a
question we'll kick over to Alicia
Krauss in five minutes and see if we've
got some answers but first I just want
to go quickly around the room what do we
think of this speech give us a quick
grade one or two lines of commentary
would you think been um I mean b-plus
the only reason it's not nays because
just so long otherwise I thought that it
was quite good I thought that whoever
wrote his speech did or did a really
good job I thought that he delivered it
well they're the the big story of the
night of course is the Democrats Mike
Pence secretly sneaked around to all the
Democrats eat put superglue on on the
actual seat because they would not get
up for anything the national anthem for
war or for war stories for like for
anything for chance of USA they would
not get up because they've determined
that they are the anti-trump party they
have no actual principles or anything
they stand for they just don't like
Trump so obviously the big moment of the
night comes
with the North Korean refugee who holds
up his crutches near the end which is a
dramatic flourish for sure and the and
again I think that he did a very good
job of using you of doing a tick that I
think that Obama did early on well and
later lost which was use unitl unity
lines and forced the other side to take
the non unity side so they say things
like protects Americans from crime from
and Democrats would sit and when you say
unifying things and the Democrats still
won't do anything that's the art of
politics that it was really well done
tonight and this this round of good
headlines I expect to last let's see at
7:00 we'll be back in the news cycle
yeah you know I basically agree with
that I would give him an A+ for the
first 30 minutes after that I don't
think anybody was listening yeah you
know but but you have to give him credit
for the strategy of the speech the
speech was put together which maybe
Stephen Miller whoever wrote the speech
speech was designed to call out the
Democrats on on major things not just
what Ben said but also their
unwillingness to compromise on the
immigration policy because he was
offering them stuff that his base hates
he was offering them basically
citizenship from millions of illegal
immigrants in in return for security at
the border and there clearly were not
going to go for it I also thought the
final moments of the speech was
sensational if anybody was still around
when you think back to Obama the notion
that the people of this country are the
source of it's not just a strength but
also of its legitimacy that that that
had been lost for eight years with Obama
he he really always looked down upon the
people of this country he said himself
like I would like to just get the
experts in a room and solve all your
problems
Trump looks to us to solve the problems
that is the American Way I don't know if
anybody was listening to that poor ation
at the end but it was it was absolutely
that was excellent and I just thought
the strategy of the speech was great it
did go along and I just I think people
it
you can't do that you can't do that but
I mean Trump should know that better
than anybody considering he's a hundred
and forty character guy like if you'd
come in anyway that's true two eighty
now if he'd come out and give it a
twenty minute speech he would never stop
being away what do you think I am very
pleased with Trump's performance of a
time know you know I will say I'm very
pleased with his performance I'm very
pleased with the writing I'm much more
pleased with the Democrats performance
they sat down for jobs they sat down not
only for low unemployment they sat down
for blow black unemployment yeah
they sat down for welders I mean for the
national anthem they sat down for the
new Zoey laughter unemployment look I
could have looked for the flag they sat
down because they had to and what I
really think we all should give Trump or
whoever wrote the speech or whatever
credit because he left them no choice
yet to sit for every one of those and it
is it was beautiful I agree and he he
did such a spectacular job and and they
did such a what a drone death
performance from people who are usually
pretty good at showbiz right the
Democrats have us beat there until we
elected Donald Trump that they think
that they can sit for think they even
sat for things that are typically their
issues they sat for infrastructure they
sat for paid maternity leave
they you know they said as you said they
sat for basically amnesty those who
don't we destroy he first makes mad well
now we want to hear what you have to say
about the speech we're gonna kick it
over to our very own designated survivor
as you know the State of the Union the
president picks one member of his
cabinet to sit outside of the blast
radius of your average nuclear warhead
we do the same Alicia Krause in The
Daily wire bunker how's it going over
there
I'm pretty good all safe over here Oh
Jared and I are fine we're taking
questions from the audience on Facebook
because as you said we're shut down on
YouTube but more about that later and we
have some lots of fun responses and
questions from people people really
don't want to hear you guys talk about
the State of the Union they want to know
if Michael Knowles is wearing a clip-on
tie I'm not gonna wanna do this tie yet
because it's I will say they don't make
novelty ties in like pure silk so it's
it's pretty starchy but this was done
all by my own honor I have never known
Michael Knowles to wear
seth has a little more serious question
for Ben he wants to know what kind of
scotch are you drinking actually it's a
multi question question what kind of
scotch you drinking do you enjoy it
is it neater on the rocks and is it
kosher before the broadcast I said we
have to get kosher whisky because
otherwise someone will ask better so yes
this is kosher whiskey and beforehand it
is Jameson and I had Jeremy tell me how
to drink it that is 18 year old sherry
cask finished Jameson how much do I like
it well let's just say that it was
[Laughter]
alright next question is for Andrew
Andrew Sarah wants to know if you were
president Clavin so if this has been
your State of the Union tonight and the
three men in that room Plus moi in the
bunker we're in your cabinet who would
be in which position wait the three men
here yes I would just be asking them
questions I would just tell me what to
do I have no idea what I'm doing yeah
that's it all right let's see I would
put Ben in any position where he could
kill people and that and of course I
would put nulls in the press he would be
the press secretary yeah Jeremy would be
the god-king and me they did it they did
include me I was there anytime you okay
yes I would definitely put Secretary of
Commerce Secretary
[Laughter]
okay because I was home-schooled
home-schooled there we go my first thing
would be to close it just like Rick
Perry wanted close all of the ones that
Rick Perry wanted to close and half the
ones that he didn't remember
Camila has a question for our God King
of course both of those are with
lowercase because we're not blasphemous
around New York she says dear God King
are you concerned about the negative
health effects from all that secondhand
smoke on the set I fear second hand
cigarette smoke which has now killed
officially more people than heterosexual
aids as I said at the beginning of the
broadcast all things in moderation one
nice thing about delicious Cuban cigars
is that you don't inhale the smoke one
bad thing about smoking in my office is
you do inhale all of the second and oh
the second I worry most for been the
rest of us probably deserve what we
deserve most of the harm goes to the
wallet rather than to the law
Margo has a question for everybody and
she wants to know do Ben Andrew and
Michael do everybody watch each other
shows yeah we're lying
I thought we were lying I'm sorry
watches every second of my show to find
the moment to fire me upon the RAM
Jeremy is the god of the daily wired
each morning I bring an offering to his
office actually burn okay so speaking of
Noel's who we all want fired sure wants
to know is it true that if he stands in
front of the mirror and repeats reasons
to vote for Democrats five times that
Michael Knowles will appear you know
John put Horowitz tweeted at us actually
I don't know if you saw this on Twitter
he said what is up with the Davenport
that has fake books in I guess there I
didn't look at the books over there but
I will say this fake books have been
very good to me put a lot of bedding in
our final question for now because we'll
be doing another round of these later
Emmanuel wants to know guys what's up
with the vegetable platter it looks
totally
that's how you know we're men to me I
love anything with ELISA thank you no
see in a bit yeah so we're standing by
for one of seventeen and a half Democrat
rebuttals no to the speech and I think
that it's fair do we do we know Willie
hands were gonna watery of Joe Kennedy's
we may have a preview of Joe Kennedy's
did we did we pull the preview for Joe
Kennedy's speech okay well if we do yeah
and we will bring that up shortly to
show you the solution so Joe Kennedy the
third yeah yeah we have a preview of
that actual rebuttal so here it is only
the grandparents love those can be the
difference between guilt and innocence
one of the things I love about America
is that anyone can be President if your
last name is Kennedy Clinton Obama is
one of those things that you're a grape
grower what I love is they had the
Democrats were like we need a fresh face
anyone a fresh face you know something
we've never Joe Kennedy the third you
know been there's there's a curse for
the State of the Union response and no
one's ever given a good one yeah their
party and who better to break a curse we
know he's good at politics cuz the last
name is Kennedy yeah boy he looks awful
yeah I remember that
remember the Kennedy Nixon debate he
learned all the wrong lessons milkman
was at Nixon should we listen America
Libya carry on that rich legacy
like many American hometowns all River
has faced its share of storms but the
people here they fight for each other
they pull for their city is a fitting
place to gather as our nation reflects
on the state of our union anxious people
are tuning in you know I know
I mean Rubio got like killed for
drinking water this guy's drooling in
fear now he doesn't have chest cuz they
can look pretty like we also I mean
Marco Rubio got killed for drinking
water if a Kennedy drank water would be
the first time he's just gonna keep on
going here and we'll just make fun of
him so now that a party the direct but
what a thankless job any State of the
Union
that's true horrible job to do the
rebuttal I feel like the Republicans
should never do a rebuttal just yield
the time back to the gentleman from
wherever wherever but especially tonight
when the Democrats basically abstained
from the speech yeah they couldn't even
support their own ideas when uttered by
the president what's a guy like the
problem with the Democrats now is that
the shutdown for jobs for America for
the flag that actually represents a
large swath of the Democrat Party it's
not an accident it is not an accident
they don't stand for the flag they don't
stand you know people have been tweeting
oh blacks have you don't have jobs so
what Donald Trump said something and you
know
about Charlottesville you know they
actually don't stand for the real things
that make people's life they stand for
the state of the government and the
state of a kind of a show business
version of governor well they have
hinted themselves in a corner with all
the intersectionality naans yeah so by
having all of these folks by colin
kaepernick neil and then saying well we
stand with the people who neil because
this country is garbage yeah or it has
been garbage historically yeah it puts
them in a position where next time
somebody says we stand for the flag they
now have to not stand for the flag so
they they had to trump force them things
smart he tried he forced them to pick
sides with Kaepernick as opposed to
playing the middle position which is
Kaepernick has the right to do what he's
doing but I disagree with that right and
he says we stand with the flag what they
really should have done is stood up and
then later they should have said listen
we all stand for the flag but if
somebody wants to not stand for the flag
drop but they couldn't do that because
they'd be alienating their own base this
is what I was saying about I think that
the Democratic Party is falling into the
trap now of just being anti Trump now
that could work in elections right it
worked for Republicans in 2010
Republicans basically ran anti Obama and
they swept so it's quite possible that
in 2018 Democrats just run anti Trump
because the truth is as much as we talk
about the State of the Union okay let's
put it this way the bleep hole comments
controversy happened a grand total of 17
days ago okay that's how fast the news
cycle is right now the government
shutdown ended a week ago yeah a week
ago okay we don't remember any of that
so the state of the idea the State of
the Union is gonna carry forward for
nine I worry about this I worry about
this because I'm watching it in Britain
I was in I happened to be in Britain
when Jeremy Corbyn was elected the head
of the Labour Party and this guy is a
left-wing jew-hating piece of garbage
he's a terrible terrible person and they
basically the headlines were the Labour
Party has destroyed itself and I said at
the time no they haven't because every
election is a binary choice and
eventually this guy's going to come up
against an unpopular Conservative
government and Jeremy Corbyn could be
Prime Minister and that is now what
they're facing and so guys like Bernie
Sanders who basically promote the Soviet
yes point of ignition they could
actually they could actually win
election this is what's the area this is
this is why Trump's popularity rating
actually does matter it does matter
you're right no you're right and and I
think the only thing I would say about
Trump is that he has laid a bet that we
haven't quite seen on changing the game
he is actually trying to change the
whole tenor on which we discuss these
topics and I'm not sure the
the polls reflect whether or not he's
won I'm not saying he's won but I'm not
sure they reflect whether I think that
it's reflected that I'm not sure that
he's won the bet but again you write
them to binary race so he's I think his
bet is the Democrats are gonna be so
dumb yeah but they nominate somebody
terrible in 2020 which is a significant
possibility Bachmann it's very possible
if they nominate somebody like Joe Biden
though it's gonna be rough if they
nominate even somebody like Bernie said
but he's been through the wringer
already you remember you can hit Bernie
with a lot of stuff but Bernie was hit
with a lot of stuff by Hillary Clinton
with the Democrat base yeah
so you know I think that Trump would go
right at Bernie but I'm not sure Bernie
doesn't go right at Trump so it's I just
think that we I remember after 2004
after Bush won reelection I wrote a
column where I thought Republicans know
I'm gonna lose again
I mean we've won three straight
elections one 2001 2002 he won
reelection 2004 even though he lost the
popular vote in 2000 I figured we're on
a roll this is this could be an era of
dominance for Republicans and I got the
same feeling among a lot of Republicans
now who just they wanted to be true it's
like we're never gonna lose again well
the Democrats until five minutes ago
thought the same thing they were never
gonna lose again and it's just not the
way that that's a balance you're
absolutely but it does get to my central
theory of the left which is that they
they want the appearance of the thing
but not the essence of the thing they
want to look they want a president who
looks like a president Oh Brock Obama he
talked like a good president the
Kennedys they look like good but they
aren't the husk of the thing and and
what's unfortunate a little bit for us
sometimes is Donald Trump doesn't look
like the president yeah he doesn't talk
like the president he doesn't behave
like the president but he is governing
like the president and that that's a
real dichotomy I've never seen it so
clearly in American politics and I don't
know which way we're gonna go it's a
superficial culture so the fact that I
think the way we're gonna go is the way
we don't want to go because we're
getting precisely the reverse of what
you would think meaning that Trump is a
visual president right he was the guy
who was a reality TV star he had no
experience in politics he wasn't the guy
he was in Paul Ryan he wasn't a
substance guy Trump is proof positive
that Americans want the image of
something well that's the image of the
President or the to the image of just
imagery no they want the image and so
the question is less image over
substance then which image to Americans
want hmm and in that moment in 2016 what
they really I still believe that the
2016 election we give Trump all sorts of
props and he deserves props for visiting
states that people like God like me
thought he was fools
time in Wisconsin in Michigan I mean
insulation but Pennsylvania but but that
election to me was still about the
awfulness of Hillary Clinton much more
than it was about the quality of Donald
Trump was a candidate because Hillary
Clinton did not pull in flies she could
not get flies I mean it was and it
there's a reason did you see the during
the State of the Union should released a
huge Facebook statement literally during
the State of the Union she released a
huge Facebook statement about how it was
wrong of her to have not fired that guy
for sexually harassing the help oh
really
yeah she released an ultimate you know
you can't you can't I
I agree with you that image means so
much in this age of media and as it has
since Nixon Kennedy but you reality does
get a vote you can't like exclude the
fact that the economy is better that
people do have jobs and people know when
they have jobs you know it's not like
you can you can have the you can have
any we are telling you that oh the Obama
economy was great but people knew it
wasn't and wages are going up and
bonuses are going up and jobs are going
up and I think that's gonna I don't want
to be the the pessimist in the room but
that is my I was born this way words the
famous thing about the way the economy
affects elections in my opinion I a bad
economy will kill a president a good
economy doesn't necessarily save one
right so in 1992 the economy was already
recovering by the time HW ran for
reelection and he lost in 2012 the
economy was recovering but when that
great and Obama won in 1980 the economy
sucked so car lost but a good economy is
not a guarantee you actually win
reelection so look does it help
yes but the economy's also a precarious
thing and I can't shake the feeling
maybe it's just a feeling because I'm
not looking at the underlying
fundamentals when I say this every eight
to 10 years in the country there's some
sort of recession right it happened in
2000 it happened in 2008 know which
means were kind of overdue right which
means the 2018 so maybe this last
another four years or maybe we go
another two years and an economic crisis
it's a direction we don't know so if
we're betting on just that then I don't
need to limit in Mississippi I meant
reality in general I mean one of the
things that Trump does that for me is an
incredible relief after eight years of
Obama lecturing us
and telling us that's not who we are as
if we are somehow better than other
people we're not our ideas are better
than other people but we are just people
to have Trump basically law of this
country law of the people of America law
to our history law our tradition I think
that this is an important thing and I I
did have this experience when I was in
New York over Christmas of people
looking me the eye and aggressively in
New York wishing me Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas
looking right-wing pet in right-wing
circles this stuff has become sort of an
in-joke and a password but I think that
what you are right about more than the
mayor of Christmas stuff is the idea
that in Trump said it and he was right
that the president is given all sorts of
credit when the economy is good and
given all sorts of the blame on the
economy's bad it's really nonsense the
truth is that the president usually has
very little to do with the economic
status of the country it's usually a
delayed effect for three or four years I
mean the idea that you're gonna
attribute like Clinton's growth to not
Reagan and Bush yeah just to Clinton is
just silly yeah but that's not a rip on
Trump what it is saying is when Trump
said that America needs a cheerleader
one of the things that the president can
do that's effective is he can make
business people feel comfortable and
this is one thing Trump has done really
well what the business community wants
even more than the tax cuts because the
economy is growing before the tax cuts
one of the things the business community
feels like is at least we know he's not
gonna clock us across the face by some
direction we don't know but with Obama
any minute you felt like he could take
the regulatory state with a brand of
people feel this - the people are tired
of having this apologize for what is
after all the engine of democracy what
is still this country is still the only
reason any human being who's in section
worked so well did not yeah I want to
challenge
I typically agree with Ben on these
questions but while I agree that
historically economic trends take a long
time we have seen something in this
presidency which is an immediate
response immediately upon his election
the stock market began to surge
immediately upon the passage taxes yeah
consumer confidence immediately upon
passage of the tax cuts companies
started announcing that they would
repatriate funds into the country the
company started giving bonuses to their
employees this is in other words there
is a there's a difference in kind yours
well I what I'm suggesting is that the
economy is playing politics right now
in a way that we have not historically I
agree that in part I think that would be
a mistake to attribute the entire stock
market surged to Trump because I was
there when Obama was president when that
long ago and we were saying yes the
economy when this would Obama took over
the stock mark was in 9000 when he left
the stock mark was at 17 so the so for
us to sit around and go well the stock
market only grow under Trump is
obviously not true but to Joyce but some
of the discrete things the IMF said tax
reform helped we know some money's
coming back or some things you can is it
I think the biggest thing that you can
attribute your Trump is not even the tax
cuts well we'll see the effects over the
coming years I think that what's
happening now is the companies are
getting smart and what they're doing is
they're saying their employees look
economic policies matter and so it's not
that Apple saw a giant infusion of cash
immediately enter their their coffers
that's right soon as the tax cut went
through it was them saying to their
workers listen tax cuts are good for us
and over the next couple years we're
gonna feel it so here's a thousand
dollar check now so you link the two
things right we're not gonna wait for
the company to grow over the next two
years and then you'll have to sort of
Intuit and something good happens so
that did not trust Obama they knew they
kept their money this is the big thing
right and this is a huge angle that all
this money is going to come back Trump
is right about this he has basically
said hey we're open for business and and
this is men like that they like us being
open even high taxes are survivable if
there's tax stability it's a problem
during the Obama era and we actually
threw a regulation yeah especially with
regulations people had no idea what's
gonna have this is why I think that you
know the economy barring some sort of
exigent circumstance it should remain
decent so long as Trump doesn't cater to
the middle now but this is what this is
what's interesting what we saw tonight
is actually the best indicator that
Trump is going to have to remain in the
conservative circle all right so one of
the things that I think I fear I know
Jeremy feared that if Trump is president
and the Democrats take over Congress he
tacks to the center-right he starts to
triangulate and he starts to try and cut
deals with Democrats it ain't happening
is the Democrats won't happen
it's not about run great no saw that
tonight he offered a couple of things
that Democrats have been hungry for
right 1.5 trillion dollars in
infrastructure spending yeah
and the Democrats are sitting on their
hands right right he's talking about
legalizing two million illegal
immigrants and bring in four million
additional right they even talk about
the legal immigrants that are coming in
he said he's gonna end chain migration
mark Krikorian is spitting mad because
Mark Krikorian of the Center for
Immigration Studies he says yeah the
problem is when he says he's gonna end
chain migration everybody who's
currently on the Chamber
waiting list gets in okay so the Tom
cotton plant originally cut off the
chain migration waiting list and people
who are on the list for the next year
but everybody else has to pull their fun
they get their money back and there and
their applications go away Trump hasn't
done that in his proposal so that means
for 17 more years people who are on that
chain migration waiting let's get in as
4 million additional legal immigrants
coming into the country into 3.6 million
right in addition 1.8 million dreamers
which is bigger than daca right because
daca was only like what he did daca only
applied to the people who have actually
registered with the federal government
he says he once do it for all the
dreamers which is people who haven't
even registered with the government yet
so he's offering all of these figlia all
of these these these what would he call
a leap fig leaf that he's offering an
olive branch
he's offering all these olive branches
to Democrats and they're spitting in his
face which means that if they take over
in 2018 it's gonna be interminable
investigations we're gonna get Democrats
going after him on sexual harassment and
sexual abuse they're gonna investigate
his finances yeah they're gonna force a
vodka and Jared to come and testify in
front of Congress they're gonna do or
they're gonna subpoena everyone and
everything they get in a separate area
that was not a good look for the
Republicans to under clinton though yeah
well they didn't have the media on their
side either
i mean it'll be interesting to see you
know when the media are hammering away
and when trend when ross perot doesn't
run right i mean the fact is that the
ross perot really shivved the
republicans a couple of times in 92 and
96 if there's no third party candidate
in 92 or 96 then bill clinton's never
president so we'll have to see what
happens you know i'm i'm but the good
news is for the economy Trump will not
sign anything they sent his way right
because he's not gonna cut a deal with
them right he's not a was anything the
entire offered it seems to me as a trap
I mean he's making this offer because he
knows I agree the Schumer has
telegraphed that he will not accept it
so now he can go on Twitter which
remember Jerry Lynn it yeah Twitter is
like a million times with the New York
Times circulation is Trump's Twitter
feed the New York Times has a
circulation point five percent of what
Trump's Twitter feed is he now goes on
Twitter and says hey I offered them
everything and they will not take I
totally heard this is why I was I was
kind of shocked that Ann Coulter I
understand that you know and and and
Krekorian they have to say what game but
the reality is that what Trump did was
not an actual off
him saying I will give away the store
and you guys still won't make a deal
with me because you hate me so sues the
art of the deal I mean it really is
kinda it's the first time I ever saw him
do something in a negotiation where I
thought that makes sense most the time
negotiation is Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer he's like okay god dang it you
think maybe that Donald Trump since
becoming president read the art of the
deal see what you have to say about it
remember if you're watching us on
Facebook to go up and hit follow so that
you help us get our messaging to you and
even beyond hitting follow if you
already do follow us go into your
settings and make sure you receive
notifications from us so that we can
actually reach you in this age of
conservative censorship and Alicia are
you with us yeah I'm here what you got
we got tons of questions but most
importantly Edward has a question for
Ben that I don't think any of us have
the answer to Ben Edward wants to know
what does your wife do for a living
[Laughter]
there's been rumors a long time she's a
doctor Wow doctor greater than John
Kasich status mail you know the most
amazing you should know this by the way
she had a her kid was sick over the
weekend and she actually texted my wife
Rebecca advisor and it was after sundown
on Saturday because some people tweeted
that to me and I was like don't worry
they're good Jews they didn't break
stuff it was a life-threatening
situation she'd answer even no it was
fine and she's a very good doctor I will
definitely go to her you know once my
covered California kicks in Nate asks of
Michael I'm going into political science
as a college major what tips do you have
for me as I go into the leftist world of
academia my first one is do not major in
political science certainly economic
advice sometimes political science
majors do well Barack Obama ben shapiro
people have risen to great heights of
doing political science
I prefer history I think political
science used to be a good field I think
now they've mostly weeded out the
political philosophy aspect of it which
is the really substantive aspect of it
so my advice to you is to study the
ancients I think we would all agree with
that don't just study
and political science I mean like the
beetle and study what would have been
the classical aspects of liberal
education - and then and probably keep
your head down in your mouth shut
because you might you might have a
little bit of trouble in college these
days if you voice your opinions all
right Eric has a question for our God
King Jeremy boring God King you seem
insightful and borderline omniscient he
wants to know do you think that
Democrats actually believe that sitting
for both the anthem and God is a winning
political strategy I think that Donald
Trump should have actually broken into
the national anthem and forced them all
to kneel what if he'd actually played
the end of Dinesh's movie I wonder why
they do like a navy state-of-the-union
they could do that now like bring out a
big screen I think it'd be fun no could
you do they could fire people on
national TV by the way I do like this
comment from Twitter Bravo to the
democratic advanced staffer who decided
to put Kennedy in front of a broken car
on national do think that they I think
that they are so in their bubble of
partisanship which is something that I
think we have to be careful about as
well no they're they're so deeply in
that that they I think they honestly
believe that people are sitting at home
slow clapping them for keeping their
seats and what they what they're
forgetting is the lessons as I said
before they're typically so much better
at media than we are so much better at
showmanship than we are the Trump's you
know Trump's a carnival barker from way
back he's just got their number and so
they're forgetting the things that they
know and one of those is that the
momentum of you can't compete with the
momentum of the speech sitting the way
they did is sort of like giving the
rebuttal to the State of the Union
you lose automatically the the reason
they've been I think all of us agree
that I'm not not drew that this entire
sort of episode of the State of the
Union the president standing like a
monarch in front of the chambers of
kasym bold Congress and and all the
applause and everything is sort of
anti-american I mean
there's a reason none of the founders
didn't do this Jefferson I did away with
it it was just a speech until Woodrow
Wilson wrote a letter
yeah washing riddler Woodrow Wilson
decided that he would give this as a
speech and it really became the sort of
progressive iconography kind of thing
and we've tried to embrace it but the
the power of that is that it makes the
executive powerful that's what the
progressive presidents wanted was to
show the power of the executive and
sitting there makes you seem inept
you're already in a situation where the
president is more where his power is on
full display and I think they were
basically showing the guy their necks I
mean I think it was a horrible
miscalculation well it reminds me a lot
of fun remember during the gore Bush
debates when Bush would say something
and and gore would sigh and hem haw
around and it looked really bad and
cousin liked it it felt exactly it says
yeah patrick has a question for Ben he
says why do you hate knowles with the
burning heat at the sun that's a song i
mean have you seen a smoking jacket an
American flag bow tie what am I supposed
to wear I sold more copies of his books
than all my books combined and there are
zero words in them but there were four
years to reach success that was a
question I thank you for asking that
Randall has a question for Andrew he
says Andrew I'm curious because you're
clearly a very productive person what
does your daily routine look like can
you enlighten us as to your discipline
ways yes first of all there's no
sleeping in my days they did sleeping
just does not exist I occasionally doze
off like during this conversation
several times but normally I'm just
awake for 24 hours a day I come in I do
my show I do a lot of show prep and then
I go home and I write for hours and
hours on end and then I go to bed and
read constantly and occasionally I must
sleep sometime otherwise I'm not human
but I don't know when I do I just don't
sleep that's that's the answer and and
I'm gonna say something about that
because one of the things that I love
about coming to work with these three
guys there ain't much one thing that is
impressive about all three of you is
your discipline you're also well-read
you're reading at the office constantly
having discussions about books that
don't have pictures in them that's
really important to a loli god-king such
as myself
but even among even in this company
Andrew Cleveland's work ethic and
discipline towers above I mean you when
I first met you you said that you work
basically you structure your day in four
hour shifts yeah and that's how you're
able to move from project to project the
way that you do and have a kind of
productivity that you have it's pretty I
would just want to say Lisa this is the
only nice thing Jeremy is Douglas has a
question for Ben he wants to know Ben
what are your thoughts on video games
and do you play any I know I I do not
play video games I did for a very short
period when I was in when I was a kid
but I just honestly sitting in front of
a screen for hours at a time why would
anyone do that yeah I mean now that now
that I'm older the truth is that now
that I have a couple of kids
they are my video game I have I have a
wife and I spend time with her in the
evenings I just don't have I don't have
time for a living you tweet you know a
doctor family position I saw some people
asking what is her what is her specialty
she's a family physician yeah that's
that's why I texted her on Saturday
night cuz I need some family doctor of
love but my final question for this
segment guys a Ben wants to know zach
has a question for Ben he wants to know
why you consider yourself a conservative
and not a libertarian okay the reason I
consider myself a conservative and a
libertarian is because on social issues
I really believe that there's a social
fabric that is necessary and that we
have to spend an awful lot of time
preserving I think the only problem I
have with libertarianism is less about
governmental ideology than it is about
social ideology there are a lot of
libertarians you tend to feel that for
example religious institutions community
organizations these things are
oppressive rather than rather than
building of the of the capacity for free
and freely govern people so when it
comes to God
mental policy I call myself a
libertarian essentially when it comes to
overall worldview I call myself a
conservative because I put a lot of
focus on the preservation of trust that
we have in one another on a day to day
level that requires social institutions
that are informal and not created by
government in order in order to fulfill
I don't know I want to kick something in
there too because it's tempting for us
in this room to think of ourselves as
libertarians
and part of that is a branding issue
because the word conservative has some
brand problems right especially we speak
to la yeah especially in LA we we all
have been various times worked in the
entertainment industry and you can kind
of you get a little grace for the word
libertarian and I think that at a
fundamental ideological level on policy
I tend to agree with libertarianism I
agree with the general notion that
basically the government's job is to is
only to protect your nose from my fists
right that that unless the government is
keeping me from infringing upon your
rights everything else should be within
my rights we're we're libertarianism has
begun to lose me as I explore its roots
to go back to Alexander Berkman to some
of the early communists they saw
libertarianism as a part of their
ideological movement they saw
libertarianism it's fundamentally a
left-wing ideology and it's it seems
shocking to us because we think in these
very rigid American political terms
between big government and small
government but what libertarianism is is
a utopianist philosophy
it's basically akin to communism whereas
the Communists believe that the original
sin is class the original sin is is
wealth divided and if we could do away
with that we could sort of have an
identity era dice that we all live in
the libertarians believe that coercion
is original sin and I think that what
makes us conservatives the Forman in
this room is that we believe that
original sin is that thing that happened
in the garden where many libertarians
and and so we don't have a utopianist
view none of us believe that if the
government gets small where the world
would be perfect that's right none of us
believe that if we outlaw abortion we'll
live in a land of happiness and apples
none of us believe that if we just
defeat North Korea the last of our
enemies will have been vanquished we
don't believe if you secure
the border the country will say we don't
believe that we believe that the world
can get better and the world can get
worse but only God can redeem and
profess that fundamentally makes us not
really well absolutely right there's
also an aspect of some branches of
libertarianism that actually is is quite
anti founding so if you read Albert nock
right if you ever read if you're even
one of the early libertarians a guy who
is sort of an influence for William F
Buckley you know not specifically talks
about how the founding fathers were busy
he buys the Charles Burien philosophy of
how the country was down a bunch of
property owners seeking to enshrine
their own interests and that's why they
founded the country the way they did and
he talked about any element of state as
being as being terrible now I'm very
anti state when the state is doing the
wrong things but there is a purview
within which the state is supposed to
work and I think that there's the art
and sort of anarcho-capitalist wing of
the libertarian movement that's pretty
wild I've said for a long time I think a
conservative libertarian merger is is
correct yeah if we if we understand that
libertarians are basically right that
the government is a problem and
libertarians basically understand that
conservatives are right that that
virtuous behavior is necessary for
logistical reasons I need to hear true
sports on this well I mean I think that
the question is what is is the
government's role and what is the
people's role and I think that that's
that's where it comes down to we all
believe in the family we all believe in
the structure of you know of sexual
restraint we all believe in the basic
conservative doesn't necessarily mean
that the government has the right to
enforce those things or it has the right
to you know restrict the way individuals
behave and that's that's a different
thing and saying you know it always
bothered me when the when Colin
Kaepernick was kneeling for the flag
everybody on ESPN said well he is the
right to do that and I thought yes but
nobody's addressing the question of
whether it's right yeah do that which is
a different question the question of
virtue is is a really big one this is
where I think a lot of libertarians miss
the boat because there's an implication
that that virtue is actually
antithetical to small government but if
virtue exists and they make the mistake
the virginals the filt pillar of smoke
right but I think that this is something
that's missed and it's even missed among
some
see and philosophers who attempt to
suggest that when you read Plato's
Republic and Plato is talking about his
kind of utopian vision of the minute you
talk about whether human virtue is
possible does the government have to
coerce you into virtue that's right
right and and the answer is no the
government doesn't have to correspond to
virtue but in order for you to make an
argument you actually have to be
virtuous on your own no and and and
Plato did write the laws after he wrote
the Republic sort of saying you know
like okay we're not going really is
Strauss is read on Plato Yeah right he
actually his read on Plato is that is
that Plato's Republic is basically a
parody of utopian philosophy with regard
to build whatever is so utopia so very
happy to announce that we have one guest
we we thought the best and the brightest
and the conservative movement they all
turned us down and we promised them
there's a door that is a Boulevard
bellicose brought by our very own hands
this is not a Cuban cigar fan I have
wagered that the only Cuban cigar you
would actually enjoy is this one it's
the most robust Cuban cigar the
bellicose so far so good if you don't
like just a ghost we do have a Padron
just in case you wanted we destroy I
wanted you to try Hawaii everybody good
it's good to see you this good to be
here you don't know that I i weld up in
tears a few times at the Ramiro so
rabbit that's his that age so much that
is an interesting question so that is an
interesting question is it my age or is
it that it was particularly
heart-rending stuff when the Korean yeah
that wanes the crutches yeah I don't
know he was Koreans like most Asians are
very controlled yeah
they don't emote easily he was fighting
back tears that the American people were
cheering him that he got to freedom I
don't know how you don't well up I mean
if there's there
very few times the left and right can
agree I think there unbridgeable divides
between them but if that didn't move you
there is something wrong with you
emotionally and morally the warm beers
what their what their son suffer that
yeah the the couples who lost their kids
to to the the gangs I mean I mean these
were these were powerful moments and you
know they're all they're all fighting
back tears maybe it happens all the time
I usually tend to read so tubes and
State of the Union addresses and and so
maybe that's why you know I think this
was particularly moving but I'm asking
you was it you know I think I think it
was and I also think it's important that
Trump understands the power of that when
you listen to the Democrats talk about
immigration specifically they never talk
about the rule of law they never talk
about the theory of what what makes a
nation a nation they only talk about the
emotion of individuals and Trump they
see and plays their game right back at
them this is Laurie saying yes there is
a sad-eyed
immigrant but here is also a sad-eyed
person who lost a job to an illegal mms
Americans are dreamers too that was a
great that was awesome line although
although it didn't match Jeremy's line
when the guy held up his crutches and
Jeremy said god bless us everyone
[Laughter]
I see your name come up on the screen
says how did that originate are you
Pharaoh I mean it is probably one of
these be careful what you wish for sort
of it I will say though that I did not
anoint myself God King Andrew claim is
me and and I didn't mean it you know
like like an ancient ruler of Egypt not
like an actual God if you are here to
free your people we've been trying to
what well did you hear the Kennedy
response actually I I have nothing funny
to say about that speech it was
disgusting yep
it was demagogic in the extreme with you
okay I'll give you my the worst of his
old demagoguery speech you build the
wall our generation will tear it down
last what I wrote in my syndicated
column today why the left is is forever
more immigrants they don't believe in
the nation-state that is what this guy
doesn't believe in the nation-state the
left has never done it proletariat of
the world unite not Germans unite not
Russians unite workers of the world
unite as the end of a communist
manifesto leftism never believed in the
nation-state I'm sure you all know a
Superman gave up his American
citizenship in the comic strip just a
few years ago he's now a citizen of the
world that's right
this is what they believe in but we
don't our team doesn't campaign on this
we don't educate America please
understand this guy Kennedy represents
the Democratic Party which doesn't
believe in borders do you understand
that Americans that's the issue this
comes on the heels of a speech in which
the Democrat as well as we've been
discussing sat for the national anthem
sat for the flag who shot Jordan dirt if
you were watching the State of the Union
did ya go on there is a applause fine
for the flag oh that's right yes an
applause line for the anthem they set an
applause line for American prosperity
they set things like they they think
they're sitting in opposition to Trump
but they're actually revealing what
you're saying that's exact don't believe
in America they don't believe in
patriotism they don't believe that I
hope that people see that because I
think we all in this room agree that on
that but I think that they don't we and
Ted you need to educate him all of us do
for sure for sure but I think the
this is the job that the media's done so
well is we all revolve around the poll
of Trump I mean Trump is the center of
gravity now and so that means that
everything on the right and the left has
been reflected through the prism of how
does this affect president Trump and his
administration as opposed to what do
Democrats actually think and is this
revealing of their thinking or is it
more that they're just opposing Trump
personally because they're trying to use
Trump's personal and popularity as a
club to beat ideas that are actually
good and and this is a perfect example
by the way I think the reason that
you're emotional about this is not
because Obama didn't tell stories he did
it's that the stories that we're told
tonight were stories that we feel have
been ignored for literally more at least
a decade and probably some of the Bush
administration - maybe longer than that
you know it specifically when the
victims of illegal immigration are
sitting there and crying the story that
was told about the the family that
adopted the kid maybe well literally
this week the Democrats voted down a law
that would have prevented abortion past
20 weeks yeah and they're I mean I
tweeted it out but it's true Cecile
Richards would have said too that heroin
mom just abort the kid then you don't
have a problem should have been talking
about saving the kid and adopting the
kid and so when we hear these stories it
feels like when Trump has talked about
the Forgotten man on this stuff we are
the Forgotten people right these are the
stories that haven't been told for most
of my life right and so even I who have
not been a fan of the president for a
lot of his rhetoric that kind of
rhetoric is really effective and really
meaningful and especially when the
Democrats are so out of care of the box
that they they say things now like
America is is no better than North Korea
like they literally say do it and then
we show a guy from North Korea holding
up his crutches saying I got out of
there and like well if you can't see
this dichotomy you don't know what
you're what you're looking at what has
been describing America as an
for the last twenty years yeah yeah I
mean Stephen Colbert definitely right
I'm sure the other day Stephen Colbert
did it openly on the show is that right
oh well because after Trump made the
comments about other countries
yeah and which by the way is it isn't
arguably true that there are other
countries that are as well you wrote
that in your piece I quoted it yeah I
mean there's there's just no question
about it but Stephen Colbert got up and
said America is the real because
we elected Trump and then in Bono at the
Grammys got up and said thank God for s
whole countries cuz if it weren't for s
whole countries we wouldn't have all
these people here and say well that's no
well the recce actually said that during
the Grammys and that no not way to
forgive me I don't understand this point
he said if it weren't for
countries we wouldn't have all these
people here we wouldn't have great
people come to America but that's not a
reason to bless s whole countries it's a
reason to bless the people who came so
he's wished but at least this isn't that
like tantamount to agreeing with the
president I don't you know I hate to
take a more cynical view about all of
this but according to Pew Research the
people that the Democrats would give
amnesty to today
vote Democrat over Republican identify
Democrat over Republican between three
times at the low a be twenty eight
twenty it is up to eight point seven
five times more like that's right high
end there that it that is the height of
demagoguery totally but you know Dennis
with something you said about about the
idea of borders and the idea of the
countries specifically you know there's
there's no question none of us would
disagree that this is becoming a global
world I mean there's not there's no way
to stop it becoming a global world I can
I can go on the computer and talk to
somebody across the world in a minute
the question is what does that look like
does that look like one bland complete
you know one people with one idea when
no competition what Trump is basically
saying is yeah we're in the business of
America okay it's a global market our
market is America our business in
America and that is a very powerful idea
I mean that's an idea this is one's week
so I feel comfortable quoting the Bible
to God blesses Abraham and says you
through you and this is fascinating
we'll be blessed
all the families of the earth and all
the nations of the earth gods for those
of us who believe that this stuff is in
a fairy tale God's ideal is indeed that
the world has families and by that is
meant a nuclear family and biblically
speaking and Nations the abolition of
nations is a catastrophe is the Tower of
Babel right and that is what they want
to do abolish the nation-state of course
it's a global world you know it's an
invitation it's really heartened me
because of preggers
per university and I got an invitation
just in the last last couple of months
from young people in in the country of
Georgia and Romania to speak to them
they don't hear these ideas I'm not this
is not an advertisement for Prager
University its advertisement for you for
us for our values I when I go to Romania
and I took the speech and when I go I
want Romania to stay Romania it is a
healthy thing to feel a bond that is
specific to me a Romanian that but to
the to the left what I just said is
quasi fascism so in in the New Testament
Paul says that in Christ there's neither
male nor female Jew nor Greek slave nor
free and one of my thoughts about the
left is if it's a Christian virtue to
think that as God that God will one day
redeem the world in such a way that
those boundaries won't exist between us
anymore what the left wants to do is put
together things that God has separated
without God oh when you take God out of
that equation there is no redemption and
putting those things back together you
know the the removal of the nation as a
secular of the nation-state as a secular
exercise isn't holy it's not it's not
part of what I would see is the design
of the earth that the earth has designed
it was separated by God only he had the
right to separate it only he has the
right in his own time to put it back
together that's but but the left and we
were talking before he walked in about
the utopianism of libertarians I heard
it yep not the left once too on the left
is still busy doing what they were doing
in the only use this one from the
Guggenheim
we Google i/o they offer the oh it's
terrible to forget I'll finish your
story then Wesley we exclusively ash in
the ladder with Crowder ugh one of the
finest ashtrays I realize that what I
have to donate to this set you guys do
not have a proper ashtray do you care
about secondhand smoke a price for it
later I know I'll be great I'm healthier
today listen to this
the Guggenheim had this about a year ago
they their newest exhibit is an all gold
solid gold toilet that's very expensive
huh
made by an Italian Court on court
artists and it operates it actually
flushes you pay a fee at the Guggenheim
and you can urinate or defecate into the
toilet good just by the way that data in
and of itself is important because the
again the godless world of the of the
left arts is filled with scatters it's
the scatological horses they love fecal
matter urine menstrual blood mucus there
they love it I can't wait to say that
quote out of context but here's the
punchline you know what the name of the
toilet the the exhibits name is America
Oh
you can literally defecate and urinate
on America at the Guggenheim Wow look at
what they did in his Christ they are
obsessed with it and all of these the
women's March and all of the Democrat
marches it's just profanities it's just
obscenities and vulgar isms so they they
yell at Donald Trump for using naughty
language every once in a while their
entire political activism but it makes
perfect it makes perfect sense you
remove the spirit and remove God what
are you left with them and that is what
you're left with right moments or
nothing elevator to
we're animals yeah and and and it and it
does you know I always do feel people
attack the left as being somehow evil
but they are they are following the
logic of the spiritual lesson world and
rights perfect sense well I mean that
you're gonna have to blame the the
problems the mankind sees on something
then in so first so for us we blame it
on human nature we say the human beings
are inherently flawed and it is why we
set all these checks and balances and we
inculcate virtue in our children and
this is why you need religion this is
why and you've got and they can't do
that because that automatically leads to
God the minute you say human nature is
flawed it's the only way that you can
cure that is by reaching beyond
ourselves to our Creator I can't deal
with that
so instead what they say is know what's
really made human beings flawed is the
rules so if we just violate every taboo
right then suddenly human beings will be
will be cured and elevated and so they
think they're actually doing a service
by freeing man of our of our weird
hang-ups about our fetishism is about
not glorifying pee and poo and somehow
are going to or something I'm gonna make
man greater and the corollary of that is
that your dignity and your self-respect
come from me that in other words I have
to approve of you in order for you have
to have self-respect so if you're gay if
you're transsexual if you're whatever it
may be the problem you have is not that
you're at odds with some kind of
archetype in yourself or some kind of
god-given archetype the problem you have
is that I don't accept you as you are
and this is it was something that I was
pointing out about that the grammys on
my show and that was the unbelievable
focus oh me too
was supposedly about more than just
don't molest and harass women it was
supposed to be about female dignity
right so to sure they're promoting
female dignity they've got women dancing
on strange like strippers I mean that
and these two things do not coincide now
it's a free country can do what you want
but the idea that this is somehow
elevating the dignity of women and that
if I don't grant you dignity it when you
are doing something that is inherently
undignified right and somehow I am
assaulting your sense of dignity that's
your problem right it's my problem for
not changing what the word dignity means
that what you're doing right now is it
the the the lapse into complete
subjectivism is is Francis why in the
1950s Dwight Eisenhower put in the
Gettysburg Address that we were one
nation under God
that was a little bit to settle it back
to Alisha and take a few more questions
one last time
questions that are being submitted on
Facebook you lis sure you would I am
still here I'm still in the bunker and
thankfully the vegetable trade didn't
make it to me like 30 miles away so I
didn't even know I didn't even notice it
was missing Johnny K says gentlemen I
believe you're blocked and deleted
YouTube live stream still has more
viewers than did Joe Kennedy's
responsibility and then if you weren't
with us YouTube blocked our livestream
for playing the State of the Union we
were using the c-span which is owned by
the government using the c-span feed
which is public domain YouTube sort of
affiliate the young turks was using the
same stream and they were not blocked
but of course there's no bias I don't
want you to get the wrong idea
so those who don't know Prager
University is currently suing YouTube
for discrimination by the I'll tell you
a story little Alicia give me more yeah
I have a powerful okay fine
so they blocked they've not blocked but
they have put on the restricted list 40
of the pre university video it must have
been with very very their radical
graphic stuff like the history of the
Korean War but we all know Victor Davis
Hanson so this this is a proof of proofs
I debated I debated a left-wing jus I'm
a conservative Jew I debated a left-wing
Jew at the biggest temple in San
Francisco last month of a guy from J
Street okay that debate is now on the
restricted list oh my goodness so half
of it is a leftist speaking but I feel
that I prevailed in that debate this is
not not bragging because that's the only
possible reason they would restrict it
right the conservative may have looked
good with a leftist that cannot be seen
50% conservative is too much that's
right
Alicia yeah Ian hatch says the question
for everyone there including Dennis that
he wants to know who is your a favorite
all-time historical military figure
mm gosh guys I mean come on
no Cohen it's not well-known he was
actually a barber the troops
I forgive me Alicia who's that for there
was so many great there's no favorite I
don't have a hey hi there were too many
Gribble who's your favorite is George
Washington because George was yeah
figured out that you could lose forever
and still win the war if you knew her
and that is one of the greats he was one
of the great secrets of great empires
great empires lose wars lose battles
continually but win the war and that was
George Washington's strategy so for me I
would have to I'd have to go with either
Sherman or with or with MacArthur who
was correct about the Korean War I know
people don't the reason that wasn't it
china still exists as a communist slave
state is because we did not listen dogs
Roy Douglas MacArthur about the
necessity for taking out China in the
great oh just just I agree with you I
just want to say on behalf of Truman he
the the fear of a war with China was
real yeah I must say there are some
there are some good Pope's at the Battle
of Lepanto the doors there were there
were the First Crusade but I will I'd
actually like to give it to a Winston
Churchill he's very popular now because
when well because Winston Churchill so
you see this is a military leader yes
military more money wasn't it wasn't
sonali's
there's a wonderful painting from 1919
that depicts all of the leaders of World
War one they're talking about a happy
they are about the peace and there's
only a light shining on Churchill he's
looking out with his head in his hands
he's so upset and Winston Churchill had
exactly the women in 19 1919 ya begun in
1919 and went on forever the guy died
before was finished but the Winston
Churchill addict he flew airplanes even
though he was a terrible pilot and he
crashed the multiple times the third
time Winston Churchill crashed an
airplane
it was nearly fatal it was a really
terrible crash and he was a war hero for
war and less over equal for one as his
first order the Admiralty but he came on
they said aren't you afraid of dying
you keep why these planes you're
obviously a terrible pilot and he said I
love life but I do not fear death and
that is exactly the right attitude those
are words look don't just say well I'm
not afraid of death I love life
yeah but I do not fear death by the way
it was largely my love of the absurd
that I said Phil :
but there was an element of truth to
that it's they're not leaders but the
the average soldier going out to the
Normandy Beach ya know it's the person I
first think of when I think of heroes
that's right in the military world
alright Charles has a question for
Dennis mr. Prager which room in your
estimation is nicer the god-king jeremy
boring his headquarters or your home
library where you film your Prager you
fireside chats wow that's a great
question since I can smoke a cigar in
both I have no be in prison I don't
really want the last dinner this
question is from Colby and it's for
everyone in the room what books would
you put on a mandatory reading list for
college students I have a list by the
way at Dennis Prager comm Alicia I have
I have a list and she'll just give a
couple ok cuz yeah thanks so the fact
that I'm hesitating is this a bad time
the Bible is so magnificent but it needs
to be understood it's like you can't
read Shakespeare today without a
commentary and let me make a plug I've
never plugged the book in my life this
is a cause not a book nobody writes a
commentary on the Bible to make a lot of
money so I'll start with that on April
2nd my comment a hundred thirty thousand
word commentary on the book of Exodus is
coming out Wow and to explain its
greatness beyond that man search for
minute meaning by Viktor Frankl changed
my life in high school I realized we
only have one
ultimate freedom when everything else is
taken away there is still one that
cannot be taken away how we react to
what happens to us you can't choose
cancer you can't choose to be hit by a
drunk driver you can't choose to have
troubled parents or trouble children or
whatever but you can choose how you
react so I'll put those in traffic
Ben and I were having this conversation
recently because of a little secret
project we're working on ears and we had
a similar concern about the bible is
certainly the book of Genesis in the
book of John are two seminal works to
understand Western civilization you need
to understand Genesis and John and I'll
say that long before we knew one another
I listened to your teachings on Genesis
that you did it at university of Judea
University of Judaism it was really
helped shape a lot of my thinking about
my relationship but it is difficult to
to point people to the Bible without any
kind of anchoring that's why I hope this
will inaugural doing the first five
books and Exodus I started with a view
copied you're not gonna give it to me
until it's already out I'm gonna give it
to you the second I have one okay you
wanna know what you want one in Word
format I'll read it I mean yeah I love
that stuff so yeah I know you do I know
we both do because we come from a
similar world where you you will totally
relate and you will find this
interesting
I don't read fast I'll bet you do right
and but I know one of the reasons I
don't we both went to yeshiva which is
half day Jewish Studies in Hebrew half
day in secular studies in English it's
very intense and we both went through
high school different ones obviously and
even at different times if you can tell
but the but there was a brilliant way of
learning why does it say this and not
this right yeah right
ice I read newspaper articles like that
why did the New York Times use this word
but not this word and and it it slows me
down but I really understand what's
going on by doing that I'll give you one
example this was Bruce her shinsen gave
this exam
Fidel Castro was always the Cuban leader
but a right-wing dictator in Nicaragua
or Dominican Republic was a dictator
right there were no communist dictators
in the new york times right there were
only right-wing dictators I don't think
we should leave out I mean I would
definitely put the bible and shakespeare
and i would trust people to find their
way back you know to the commentaries
thing i think that if you read the bible
with an open mind and you don't go in
with the perversely anti-biblical
mentality of the new we're just going in
to just be angry in a way I think that
you just said something important
because I was going to suggest that you
guys bring a lot of nonfiction I read
fiction and I find truth in fiction I'm
a story Tom a Hollywood guy when you say
the bible and shakespeare i think you
are providing a commentary on the Bible
also true fiction should lead you to the
truth I also think I also think we could
not leave out some Plato and Aristotle
and specifically the some Plato's
symposium but that doesn't you know
these have to be done I think if they do
have to be what I'm I guess when I'm
picturing when when we were asked this
questions like what's a violin sort of
where we have nothing else but this
what would I start with and it would be
because when it comes to books that I
would just start with that don't require
a commentary and start with like
economics in one lesson by Henry Hazlitt
it'd be a history of the American people
by Paul Johnson sir you're great things
in let's see this because because Dali
you can read on it but this is stuff
that you can read on your own and
understand but in terms of kind of
foundations of Western civilization of
course if you're gonna start with the
basics but you require a teacher I mean
all the stuff requires arrived I mean in
the Jewish in the inside of the Jewish
parlance to learn it Plato Aristotle
it's very difficult to learn I know I
know because I'm doing some remedial
reading of it now yeah and and it really
is something that has to be commented
upon and taught and even if you read
natural right in history by Strauss
which is a commentary on this stuff you
need commentary on Strauss in order to
understand sorrows yeah are we leaving
out the obvious reasons to vote for
Democrats
but that really needs a teacher really
does have to go I am here for you and I
would also I would a lot of books aren't
taught anymore they used to be you they
would be taught so Dante I think is not
taught as much
I think the comedy offers as much as it
were all white there's a little swarthy
is worthwhile these philosophers are
tough I mean reading reading Conte is
almost impossible right oh so it so it
will Durant's summary of various errors
and their main points then actually
struggling through the word by word of
some mystery for Aristotle by the way
who's actually pretty terse symposium
and the ethics are very basic a very
dramatic and and quite clear and and
that you can those are the foundations
you can't have the gun you can't have
the Jenga tower starting at the top I
mean I totally in the body not only do I
agree with this I'm writing a book on it
right the book and the book is about the
the why it is that we have fallen into
political tribalism so strongly and it
seems to me that it's because we have a
god-shaped and reason shaped hole in our
hearts that's now being filled with
passion and tribalism so and so what the
first third of the book is just tracing
the foundations of Western civilization
then nobody learns so there's a full
chapter on the Hebrew Bible and then
there's a full chapter on Plato and
Aristotle and then there's a chapter on
the New Testament and it literally moves
forward in history like that through
Aquinas I'm right now I am up to I'm up
to Aquinas and then and then I actually
get to Machiavelli at the moderns but it
but it's this stuff is not taught at all
so I'm trying to I'm trying to simplify
it enough that people can actually
understand Alicia did you expect such a
long for me that's for the audience the
audience is like wait what was the
question I know that's wrong just wanted
to know
illustrated the destruction of the
American soul braid enlarged says any
lists without fifty shades of gray
trilogy on it oh yeah absolutely
okay final question is from Melissa and
she has a question for Dennis and Andrew
the most wise gentleman in the room she
says she actually called you she calls
you wise elders I mean hey that's in the
bible we're supposed to respect you
right Melissa says why oh why have you
lived in California for so long when
does it become too wacky a state to live
in
that's a great question that was an
excellent question I think by it was it
who one of you I think made the point
maybe what I know it wasn't me that's
all I could say and I never want to take
credit for an idea that is in mine
Wheatley that's another thing we learned
in yeshiva right but somebody pointed
out that Southern California is really
the hotbed of young and resurgent
conservatism yeah I mean all of our
groups and our our own selves or are
just examples of it so it's an
interesting phenomenon I don't I can't
fully explain it hi Shirley I'm sorry
fire refines we're all right but no York
is fine enough no well you know may have
City Journal they have some good stuff
but but III will but and San Francisco
doesn't have any of this so its Southern
California but I will say this the truth
is I love it here I I hate to admit it
but I do and I'm I bet you do too to a
large extent and yeah and you know what
there are a lot of wonderful people here
that's the thing they were really are a
lot of wonderful people and also I I'm a
big believer that without friends it's
very hard to navigate life that's
smallest and my friends are here here we
do
[Laughter]
where's friends but he doesn't
acknowledge different answer I am a
person who loves the countryside
I love being by myself I love being out
in the wilderness and yes used to winter
in New Hampshire yeah and yet I have
spent I've spent most of Connecticut
most of my life in coastal cities and
the reason for that is I am a culture
guy and my culture creator and I'm
someone who believes in fighting for the
culture and one of the things that
drives me crazy about conservatives is
they want to affect the culture but they
don't want to get the mud of the culture
on their hands and I believe in being
part of this of this enterprise part of
the centrosome party and the culture is
created no matter what anybody thinks is
created in LA and it's created in New
York and even though I'm not always
comfortable in these cities I'm really
comfortable in these businesses or
thrive here doing what you do even if it
means fighting my corner which I don't
mind well one of the I give a little
speech sometimes to young conservatives
who want to move into politics or for
entertainment and they're usually in the
groups that I tend to speak to a young
Christian idealistic often home schooled
and I often tell them that the three
most corrupting influences ever devised
by man or wealth power and fame but we
all hope to willed those very powers in
some way in service of our values and
one of the things that I cautioned them
about is you will be scarred you know
Moses didn't get dinner the land of
promise and we I think we've all burned
our fingers a little bit with our
pursuits but at the same time God's put
us in a position where we've been able
to willed them on behalf of what's good
to your point though you said so
eloquently about friendship and I agree
with that CS Lewis says you have to live
where your friends are but Don Henley
mmm
said it this way about LA let's go down
to the sunset grill watch the working
girls go by watch the basket people walk
around and mumble gaze out at the Auburn
sky maybe we'll leave come springtime
meanwhile we'll have another beer what
would we do without these jerks anyway
and besides that all our friends are
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Alicia thank you so much and to everyone
watching on Facebook and previously on
YouTube we're grateful for your time
tonight grateful that you hung out with
us for a little bit and are thankful for
your questions we're gonna let Alicia go
home and have a wife and we're gonna
wrap up with ten more minutes of
visiting together and hope to see you
all back tomorrow morning for the guys
and all their and all their content
bye guys Thanks you told me we have to
do a show tomorrow are you ready for a
great Fame story yeah so what if it
doesn't have groupies now this video is
just was a truly great humbling moment
for me so I feel funny saying but it's
still stupid not said I I am all not
always but I every day somebody
recognized me okay it's inevitable I've
been my guest you on planet earth that's
right my wife to pick me up about a year
and a half ago and this young Hispanic
woman keeps looking at me which is
already flattering and and that's great
and so on and that happens a lot people
are debating whether they should come
over okay finally she gathers the
courage to walk over and she goes are
you and whenever people go are you as is
sort of a joke I go yes pleasure to meet
you and so are you and I go yes Phil
Jackson
[Laughter]
one of the great comments on Facebook
that I saw a second ago was a traitor
and Shapiro in the same room is like
having the white and green power ranger
on the same so now and now when I asked
just randomly Dennis you don't read
fiction much correct okay so dude but
you have read some I assume you've read
our fiction book oh of course I mean I
can't graduate high school without
having burned college and by the way I
love great fiction I just had to make a
decision at a grand point what do you
write yes that was it okay but I'll ask
you because it's it off-the-beaten-track
question so what let's go around and do
like two favorite fiction books mmm
that's kind of fun do you know oddly
enough this really stayed with me a book
by emile zola l'assommoir which is the
the butchery I lived it I lived in
France and once of the nineteenth
century and I it made a deep impact and
here's another one that people probably
never heard of it's probably because I I
specialized in communist Affairs I was
at the Russian Institute at Columbia and
I were studying Russian I've been to
almost all the communist countries and
here's a novel which absolutely competes
with 1984 to explain what life in an
animal farm what life under communism is
like it's one of the least well known
books of aim Rand we the living yeah
that really gives you an idea of what
life under communism is like okay drew
since you're the most well-read person
in the room when it comes to fiction I
think by a long shot
yeah well I mean I always say that the
the novel that affected me most beyond
by a longshot his crime and punishment
I'm doing the same thing I was 19 the
first time I read it I was surrounded by
the new relativists who are just rising
up the new multiculturalist and and
Dostoyevsky basically makes the case
through an incredible great mystery
suspense novel he makes the case that
there is a world
Rick to the world the hot was right
there was a moral law within a starry
sky above and those are the two
realities and I read that book and I
remember putting it down and literally
putting my face in my hands and thinking
that's right that's undeniable you
cannot deny that and it changed the
course of my life it turned the ship of
my life toward now I'm gonna and I'm
gonna give you a gift that will Bowl
over any Russian okay ready
this is Crime and Punishment in Russian
crystalline yet not kazamia as I always
say Dennis Prager collude with the
Russia and since we're doing two books
only recently I read this like two years
ago the most entertaining novel I have
ever read it's free I'm a slow reader I
I am I think I may be a little dyslexic
got so slow this book is 1,400 pages
long I read the last 500 pages in a
single day and that is the Count of
Monte Cristo demise it's less fender
dumbass that's amazing yes he's so great
but this book is so entertaining because
it starts out as a typical you know what
call swashbuckler terrain swashbuckling
adventure and then it becomes this deep
meditation on the romance of revenge and
it's really a book about how revenge
belongs to God and yet Jim cow feels
pretty good I hear it's pretty good it's
pretty good I like that Milan action
because this book just did you know
story about Alexander Dumas
he was not paid by the workers paid by
the line so yeah actually that's oh
really so what was the fees paid boy
Dickens was supposedly paid by the word
but he was actually paid by the
installment I think by today but the the
story about Deema is that he would write
characters who would only say these very
short lines of dialogue with one word
dialogue specifically and so when the
newspaper came back to me cuz all these
things were sterilized in the newspaper
came back to him and said we're no
longer than we pay by the line he killed
off one of his characters like
think I got off one of the best one of
the best tweets I've ever gotten off and
no one got of course because there's a
story about in Russia a dog shot its
owner like got ahold of it got a gun and
shot its owner and so I tweeted out
something like and I want to get the
wording correct it was something like
why would a good dog let bad things
happen you know the wonderful thing
about crime and punishment is it is a an
answer to me Jay
but Nietzsche hadn't published anything
yet and he just does definitely did this
continually he saw communism coming he
was a seer he was a genuine seer and he
saw this argument coming down the pike
and he answered it before anybody made
it he knows have a favorite translator
by the way yes the latest one how can
you name it no Constance Garnett is
really dated and she also would cut
anything dirt she was like a nice
Victorian Maiden
it's been kind of anything sexual out of
the the newest one by it's by a married
couple whose name I don't remember but
it's PI to a man and a woman is
excellent I think you just translated
war and peace also I think it's a great
translation it's really really good s
and their and their crime and punishment
which I read only a couple years ago
it's great so Noel's he you actually
read books you know that's not right
occasionally saw me so I read more than
I write that's for sure
I well I hate to be the poor man's
Andrew Clavin I was my favorite novel is
a crime and punishment I thought I was
the poor man's I'm the one I would
recommend that isn't read a lot but I
think is really good is eeprom SE Sposi
by mun sony it's an honor it's a book
that will never be taught because of
that it's a it's the betrothed it's
about the metro so it's a wonderful you
know it's a it's a wonderful novel and
not a soul reads that other than people
who read Italian and it but it's really
good you should definitely read it it's
much below yeah I've only read about
five or six novels in my life and that
you know that is one of my favorite
novels is also one of your favorite
novels I don't let's steal it because
it's it's a better your favorite novel
than mine I'm gonna go with a popular
piece of Pulp Fiction modern fiction
because it affected me at a young age in
the same way that crime and punishment
affected you and
then it helps shape my view of the world
when I was when I was in a theologically
and politically formative time and it's
by a living author named Stephen lawhead
and it's called
it's just I know this thing you get to
clean this one you-you-you recommended
it to me so it's actually a trilogy of
books about our three and written
Pendragon sight now and I read this when
I was 18 years old I I had an overnight
radio station on today's hit country
came from below yeah and as I was
playing where was a in Lubbock Texas
metropolis or oh you're from a little
bit and I read these books which were
really about the collapse of Romanism in
Britain and the beginning of
Christianity and and I recommend them
then you read they're very good and they
they really help teach me about what
motivates people and I think that's what
great fiction can do that's what great
store great film helps us understand
what causes new our motivations I'll
brag on Clavin for a moment and say that
I think Andrew where your fiction is at
its best is when you write the internal
monologue of a man what he actually is
thinking about I really I want to push
you to actually give up the thriller
writing and just write a book that is an
internal your book the great good thing
is so that because it basically is that
it's just her internal monologue so I
mean if you did that uh I'll go a
different directions talk about my least
favorite book and it's a it's a book of
just the last couple of years and it's
called based on the true story by Norm
Macdonald and the whole of this this
book which the four of us read piss me
off it's it's supposed to be a celebrity
tell-all only one of those salacious
details yeah and and the only actual
telling all that he does is a story
about him going to prison which I don't
even think is true and the big reveal
that uh Rodney Dangerfield got no
respect I feel like this is the worst
book yes that is carrot top you
know the worst book is reasons to vote
Democrat that make
it's a quick read I mean let's say that
all a terrible memoir as novels go based
on a true story is the funniest thing in
terms of funniest things I've ever read
that aren't fiction Adam Carolla's first
book in 50 years we'll all be checks
that's good hysterically funny but as
far as favorite novels for me so my
anti-communist novel since we all have
an obligatory one is darkness at noon by
Arthur Kessler awkward which nobody read
now it's amazing I'll say really short
quickly yeah and it's just fantastic
Moby Dick was it was my favorite book
for many many years because III think
that every if you're a religious person
you haven't gone through this struggle
of why does God do what he does which of
course is the same thing as crime
punishment a really more of Brothers
Karamazov then you haven't been
religious personally the great myth
about religious people is that we don't
think about these things all the time
the whole day you know it's when when
you talk to people like when I when I
when all debate when I'll debate Sam the
Senators and we'll talk about atheism
and he'll act like the the problem of
theodicy has never occurred to religious
people forgive me I have to tell you
this quick anecdote I was invited to
their credit by the American atheist the
biggest atheist organization to debate
there their head in Minneapolis a number
of years ago after or during the debate
I looked at the audience all of whom
were atheists and I said would you raise
your hand if anything ever happens like
the birth of your own child that ever
ever even prompt you to question your
atheism not one hand Wow Wow yeah that's
a great seer then I said you know I
don't I've never been with a religious
person who didn't question there's a
great question this is Ray if you don't
a theist are significantly more
religious than religious people like
this actually sam harris intimated
actually said to him you're a more
religious person than I am and I'm the
one on stage wearing a yarmulke but it
didn't but yeah so Moby Dick is up there
the the the pasteboard masks speech if
you haven't read the book the speech
where where I have talked specifically
about how he sees Moby Dick as a
pasteboard masks and if he can pierce
through the pasteboard masks and get it
God I mean the whole story is really
about him trying to take revenge on God
for having
this whale to them and it's it's
just it's just fantastic so I love that
book there's a there's a book that my
mother Thorian book is actually th
White's once and future king the second
half of that book is fantastic first
half a little long but second half is
really great but a book that nobody
knows but I recommended to Drew and you
liked it was every man die yes it was
every man dies alone yeah by Hans falada
which is a little-known German author
who lived under the Nazis was imprisoned
under the Nazis and the entire book is
about this couple it's just fantastic
it's it's about this couple these older
couple whose son was in the German army
and has died in the German army and now
that and now that couple is trying to
figure out a way to kind of live with
each other and they're so angry that
their son has been killed in Hitler's
war that they decide that the only way
they can stand up against this is to put
out these pamphlets these propaganda
pamphlets anonymously just in the middle
of the public thoroughfare and it's and
that the whole thing is about how
they're drawn closer together as human
beings by fighting for this cause even
though they know that the cause isn't
gonna do any good and they know that
this is in essence futile but they fall
in love with the romanticism of the
cause and it's it's just it really is
it's great writing actually it's a weird
book because it's such a bleak story but
but it's really uplifting this works I
know I love that feeling I mean it's
rare that it's like a Shakespearean
tragedy like I'm finishing Shakespearean
tragedy and there's something about it
where you don't feel like this is uh I'm
trying member the name of the Walter
Kerr the former critic for the New York
Times say he brought wrote a book called
comedy and tragedy and what he said is
that comedy in the end is slightly
depressing and tragedy in the end is
slightly uplifting guys brawl in
cellblock 99 we've been we've been live
on the air for four hours now and there
are still two thousand people braving it
with us and I feel like it would be a
disservice to keep them up too much long
yeah and let me just say this has been
exactly what I had hoped for which is
not just as talking about politics all
night but it's actually just enjoying
each other's company and having the kind
of conversations that we get to have
with one another on a regular basis but
that other people don't really get to
ever hear us having because they usually
just get the product right the result of
these conversations is what makes the
dennis prager shows what makes the ben
shapiro show makes the Andrew Clavin
show those just make stuff up completely
different but this is this
the beauty of the beautiful part of our
life and the beautiful part I think of
our working relationship so I want to
thank all of you for being a part of it
tonight though I do think that we should
end with a political observation since
that is our mo mo and so if we can just
go around and very briefly the speech
tonight I think we all have similar
feelings about State of the Union
generally but what do we think is coming
you know that's the number one thing
that people want to know when they asked
us questions in the in the thread and
elsewhere they want to know what we
think is coming you know people
especially in this media environment
don't feel like they're getting they
don't feel like they're getting a
straight answer and they feel unsettled
they don't know what's coming we don't
know what's coming either
that's not our purview but what is the
political season what's in front of us
where do you think that Trump's next
move is going to be and is it something
that people on our you know conservative
should look forward to or be concerned
about you're looking at me I'm looking
at you oh I know what's coming actually
and I never predict the future more hate
the the left yells at us for hate was
there a word of hate said at least since
I've been here or heard you guys before
they yell at us for hate but I never
hear the hate that they're talking about
I I don't know where where is it
I guess I'm oblivious to it but I don't
see it I don't hear it they hate they
hate us all of us it's not just Trump
they wouldn't hate pence they wouldn't
hate Cruz I mean please they hated
george w bush the mr. compassion the
nicest guy ever yeah frightening ly so
but that's what's coming and we never
try to shut them up
no we don't and look I understand with
this I
whenever I talk privately with
republican congressmen or senators I
have the same exact message you are not
when you run for office you are not only
running you must not only run against
your opponent you must explain to the
vote
the left is destroying Western
civilization generally an America
specifically that's why you have to vote
for me even if you don't like me because
we this party the Republican with all
its fools and flaws and everything is is
the boy with the finger in his dike the
left doesn't give a damn about retaining
America as America and you if you say
that that's powerful did you stir do you
agree with ask every Republican should
ask the person they're running against
do you agree with congressman Kennedy
that this if we build a wall you'll tear
it down they will that that it that is I
want to know your answer am i worthy
opponent here in Missouri that's that's
what needs to be done the big issues you
must get on to the big issues and and
that's the only way that we have to
educate Americans about the threat that
they pose and so that I mean I I
obviously grew at the 30,000 foot
analysis what's gonna happen next
tomorrow morning strip to tweet
something and we'll talk about the State
of the Union I mean I think that the
next thing that happens this week
because I mean I have a better track
record to predicting what happens this
week three months out and Michael
Knowles has a check to prove it among
others many others but I think that the
the the memo the release of this house
intelligence memo which is gonna happen
later this week is gonna blow all of the
coverage of the State of the Union off
the map
everybody's gonna be talking about the
State of the Union for the next 30
seconds as soon as we sign off that's
pretty much it and then the memo I mean
Trump apparently wants to release this
memo and so we're gonna get a giant
fight over a memo whose underlying
intelligence no one in the public has
read and this I think is deeply
troubling I think that people want the
fight more than they want to know what
the fight is about anymore and we have
to this is why I agree with Dennis that
we have to get back to fundamental
principles but that also requires a
certain level of intellectual honesty so
before I condemn the entire FB consign
the entire FBI to the flames of
perdition and say that everything the
FBI is doing on anything or special
accounts or Mueller that all of that
stuff is nonsense I want to see all the
information coming out so I think that
we
not only as conservatives but just as
decent human beings we should say let's
see all the information let's call let's
call lies what they are I mean the idea
that Trump Russia collusion there's been
no evidence to prove that whatsoever but
let's also wait for all the information
to come out because if we don't we're
gonna get dragged into a really nasty
partisan fight particular over the next
couple weeks with the Democrats
releasing their memo and noon is
releasing his memo and none of the
underlying material being released into
the public and we're gonna hear
Republicans claiming that the FBI needs
to be shut down and then by the
President to declassify the I want the
president's declassify as much of this
as humanly possible so we can get to the
bottom of this and then we can actually
determine what's real and what's false
and by the way it's quite possible that
the FBI did nothing wrong in launching
the investigation but still came up with
nothing right it is quite possible that
all of that the FBI was compromised on
Hillary but not compromised on Trump
Russia it's possible they're compromised
on everything but what I'd like and I
think what we're we're conservators are
gonna be safe is is not by making bets
on stuff that we don't know but simply
by saying things that we do and right
now we just don't have enough
information to say what's going on yet I
think you know just as my role in our
group I have to take a somewhat broader
cultural view I think we are in a
strangely beautiful moment I think that
for the last maybe fifty years a fog a
smothering fog of political correct
silence has been wrapping itself around
us and silencing not only what we say
but sometimes even what we are allowed
to think and I think that fog has been
blown away and it has not just been
blown away by Trump he's a
representative of the fact that the
people in America are not like the
people in Europe they will not sit and
mutter into their beer they will
ultimately rise up and say you know what
you're lying
we won't lie we're not going to tell
lies and suddenly it has become alright
to speak the facts again not you know as
you say then it's not hateful facts it's
not hateful to say that terrorism is
inspired by Islam it's not hateful to
say this crime in black neighborhoods
it's not hateful to say that men and
women are different it's simply the
truth it's hateful not this it's hateful
not to say it because keeping the truth
from people simply makes them enraged
over time I think what's what's
strangely why I say this is a strangely
beautiful moment is because it's like
lancing a boil there's a lot of pain
involved in this truth that has been
hidden suddenly
coming out and you notice it in this but
in this very moment with this FBI thing
it's painful for me for you to see an
organization I've worked with FBI people
as a reporter
they're usually incredibly competent
incredibly talented people I feel deeply
for the little guy
Atlanta the Atlanta Bureau who's busting
some criminal who's now stained by what
happened in the Obama administration
this foil has to be lanced and I think
that a lot of the pain that we're
feeling a lot of the division we're
feeling is is a good thing it's a it's
letting this poison out this poison of
silence this poison of lies that we have
been surrounded by and people like us
you know we only have our little corner
to fight but we are saying what we mean
we're saying what we think and that's
that was not happening ten years ago and
that's a that's an amazing thing it's a
beautiful thing and I try to keep that
in mind because I understand the
divisions are painful and the exposure
of the truth is painful but what we're
going toward I think is actually a good
thing more honesty more truth and more
simple reality I agree with all of that
I think it's quite important to be
especially going off what you've said
Dennis it's important to be wise as a
serpent and innocent as a dove the
Democrats are innocent as serpents and
wise as hell many times Republicans and
they may have been wise as does they're
all they're innocent as doves
they haven't captured what reality is
throwing at them and what we saw tonight
in the speech what we saw in how Donald
Trump played the Democrats and forced
them into a corner is that I think this
guy is wise as a serpent and I think
he's innocent as a dove from this first
year that we've seen from him in a in a
very political sense and I think that's
very encouraging
I leave this note for you using the word
innocent with regard to president or me
yeah I think everyone I agree largely
with what everyone said I would add to
your concern about Lansing the boil
though
true that it's not only the truth being
revealed that's painful but the process
by which truth is currently being
revealed is also painful I think for
people like Ben and I in particular in
this company that's been one of the the
biggest challenges over the last year is
that Trump is a blunt instrument
and he's I don't think that he is
necessarily motivated by the things that
motivate the five of us the the
philosophical things that motivate the
five of us the values that motivate the
five of us but by this weird moment of
Providence he he is largely being used
to advance the things that motivate us
and I don't say being used as always a
puppet that's not what I mean to imply I
think it's far more complicated than
that I think for example that Donald
Trump's history has been far more less
than his presidency has been I think
that if Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi
hadn't been reactionary partisans they
probably could have made deals with him
early in his presidency and he would
have been happy to have signed deals
that would have made many of the people
who supported him on this couch very
upset but strangely he is the man of
this moment where their their inability
to grab an advantage for partisan
reasons created a framework in which
Trump has operated as a great advocate
of of our policy preferences what what
concerns me from the speech obviously
the same things that concern everyone
here you know the talk about paid
maternity leave
talk about trillion dollar
infrastructure spending I'm worried
about his tendencies towards less policy
what gives me hope is the fact that the
Democrats couldn't even come after those
things I think that they're if you'll
excuse the term constitutionally
incapable of making deals with him and
that leaves us in a great position where
we could we could see voting the most
conservative year of governance that's
what our lifetime yeah yeah and and to
the original question of business is
never Trump a continuing phenomenon and
and is it a continuing if it is is it a
major continuing phenomenon you know
we'll well know the answer to that in
three years because never Trump was
fundamentally in an electoral
consideration I think it's fair to say
that even many of us who dislike the
President on a character level are gonna
have a very hard time making some of the
arguments that we were making in the
last election when he was an unknown I
didn't see any reason to be confident
he would advance our policy agenda the
proof is in the pudding so far he really
has it been star our policies and and
that definitely has to change the
calculations the other thing that
changes the calculation even on the
character side is that Trump has been
the president and so if your fear was
evident he doesn't have the if he if you
say he doesn't have the character to be
President well that's no longer right
there's no longer speculate about the
damage or the benefit because the
benefit will be there and then you can
make a call yeah that's exactly right so
I think a lot of the things that have
divided us as Republicans over the last
18 to 24 months then we're gonna see the
party consolidating more and more back
to its old sort of framework not
necessarily changing all of our opinions
about Trump but changing our view of
what Trump means in the moment in which
we again thank you to everybody who who
tuned in for the last four hours want to
thank the guys we want to catch us you
can come over to the daily wire.com
we'd love it if you'd visit us love it
even more if you would subscribe and
especially dennis prager for joining us
the Dennis Prager show naturally
syndicate and Prager University
named after his uncle Murray thank you
guys very much the American Dream is
Donald Trump
you